everyone
it's me another day jesus christ another
day
another video just because i'm out
traveling doesn't mean the videos stop
i know that's why we have this amazing
new setup
that is not too close up at all this is
nice and intimate aren't you enjoying
this
stream fails that's what we're talking
about today
i never done one so i can't really
relate to what we're about to witness in
this video
good job felix but here are some epic
stream fails
of not just people making mistakes but
getting trolled epic style by the
viewers
which again i cannot relate to because
i've never been trolled by the viewers i
am just too smart for that
it does not happen and i want to start
this off with the reason why i'm making
this video because it's my favorite clip
of all time
i'm laughing just thinking about it poor
innocent girl just wanted to play
minecraft
i couldn't find a better quality why is
it so bad and someone in the chat i
can't believe how you can sink this low
it's super worthwhile hold the pickaxe
look at lava
push q someone comments
it's super worthwhile it's super
worthwhile
look at lava and press q okay
look at lava
oh her poor pickaxe
she threw it right into the lava this is
so sad
but wait again why are you guys so mean
to me why
why it only works with oh i'm so i'm so
stupid so the person comments again i
can only imagine i don't see the chat
it only works with diamond pickaxe the
first pickaxe you sent
into the lava that's too cheap you need
to throw in the
time i did that with my other one
you gotta you gotta appreciate when you
acknowledge that you're really stupid
and then you do something even more
stupid
i don't wanna fault this girl i would do
the same thing to be honest
if i wasn't so goddamn smart never have
i been trolled
in winnie the pooh if tigger was black
what would
okay all right shout out to my boy nikki
gears
oh my god jesus christ felix what are
you doing
read this message before saying it stop
saying
when i said it i should why did i fall
for that jesus christ
you can go third person with q just
don't do it on the horse it's a bit
buggy
just don't do it on the horse it's a bit
buggy press
q in the console
[Laughter]
how could you be so stupid
i would never fall for something like
that this is the reason i don't live
stream
this don't do it on the horse it's a bit
buggy well played yeah i guess
my dixie wreck what's up
oh it's funny where they realized right
after
what's up my bro i just shat my pants
let's get this bread guys oh
damn it come on man
i thought it was like dixie or something
are you gonna do that old are doing
special attack
hold our do special attack it resets the
game jesus christ
that is such a dick move oh my god
i kind of want to just make a game for
streamers
and have one button that just flips
everything up why is this funny it's
really not funny
but it's also hilarious
my mom's here no can't you sub another
day some another day huge load of semen
then oh god
mom i don't know who that is
there's this some troll you never know
who's gonna
dang it just having to explain that to
your mom as well that just makes it ten
times better
who is this huge long can you imagine
having that conversation with your mom
just sub another day please god damn i
can't tell if this is one of the things
where i
just me think think it's funny or not
just because i can see myself in this
situation and it would actually happen
to me
and it's the only reason i don't stream
anymore because i'm just getting
cybernetically bullied
just kidding okay i would never fall for
your foul tricks
these burnt fools i swallowed
great
[Music]
that is ice ice ice
that's how they write it i swallowed it
the thing is like you're streaming it's
so hard to
it's so hard to be streamer guys you
just don't understand
but your your focus is so shifted on so
many things already like it's not just
the game but
also the chat and trying to understand
what is happening
really got to be good at multitasking so
then when people catch you off guard
with that kind of message i
i get it okay okay hey look it's forsen
space
ah you fool forsen
what is happening precious space
proceeds to masturbate what the [ __ ]
sarah there is no donation
stop there's no he already raised it
what are you saying it's not a donation
there are resubs
tiger harvest thank you for your sub
gully lord thank you for your five
months
uh crispy thank you for your four months
uh travio man
uh thank you for your six dollars i'm
tim son
someone i already i don't notice
anything shout out to mike hawk
meredith thank you for your sticks
no one reacted to my wife no one just
shout out to my dick
just want to interrupt this video and
give a huge shout out
to my butthole i love what it doesn't
register either it's equally funny
and no one
no don't do it g4
what's up chunks what it doesn't work
oh god oh no three zeros in one g
oh and one
g
do your y'all's codes are [ __ ] busted
make sure you're typing the right thing
dude oh
i don't know how i feel about this not a
third time please
try hex please please
oh my gosh
i'm so messy i'm so mad i'm [ __ ]
this is a great compilation by the way
i'm sure every chat is going to be like
i already saw this video i know but it's
funny
okay who's been
taro oh it's about hold on
smash like if you got trolled as well
let me know
so i know who's a headphone user and
smash
like twice if you have the razer
pewdiepie headphones
just so i can know if you're a headphone
razor pewdiepie user
goddamn whoever did that two questions
this time
uh one of them is medical related and
the other ones not which ones you want
first uh the non one first let's start
with that
is it just me or does it smell like yup
dogging yeah
does it smell like what oh no dog dog
dr murphy please yep what's that
sorry what's up dog
he kicked him out why is up dog funny
it's the
lamest joke of all times the lamest dad
joke
ever crafted you get hit by an up dog
you might as well just end your career
right there
my dad died it's a very sad one please
be quiet and dedicate 30 seconds to his
favorite
30 seconds oh that's nice
for a 30 second silence
oh my god oh my god is that
only use me blade the modern warfare 2
guy that only uses his blade
do you guys remember those days or is it
just me hey sips i'd just like to say i
appreciate everything you do and think
you're a very attractive man and i
aspire to be just like you one day
nice just kidding you [ __ ] degenerate
770 seven people
this is so disgusting i hate this so
much
whenever you read a nice comment on
youtube and like oh that's just so nice
finally like a really nice comment i
haven't seen those in days
literally years i can't remember the
last time anyone said something nice in
general with my name regarded to it
and then you and you keep reading and
it's like by the way check out my
channel and like god damn it
my crew cheese hairy even what excuse me
like who cheese hair even what
say that again mike who cheese harry
it's time to stop please i don't know i
don't know i
literally don't know what you're saying
i don't know what's happening
oh someone wrote it oh my god
oh god it's not funny this is so
childish and stupid
but also it's hilarious
and i love it dr
is
the delivery absolutely impeccable
i really appreciate the people taking
the time out of their day
just for that one moment just for that
one moment of epic trolling
that's it that's all the time we had for
today's streams
fails epic trolls if you're an epic
trollsters
leave a like just so i know if you are
and also
check out merch link description i think
you will like it
very much and now i'm gonna go
and explore nihon everyone
bye bye tuber simulator it's now
so relevant that it's got a brand new
minigame
craniac drop the crane and get fresh
items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more
of course there is new knowledge perks
new quests
and new pixellings and legs
guys like